it's absolute insanity what you are able
to do and you're doing a lot of it on a
lot of these stunts are on hard ice
incredibly hard ice and I'm thinking if
you slip up you can get seriously hurt
do you wear padding when you do this and
like I wear a helmet you wear a helmet
and then nothing else I would be wrapped
in just pillows if I was doing what
you're doing yeah I mean you're totally
allowed to I just I don't know I don't I
think it would like not really help
really know at the speeds you're going
and hitting a hard ice no amount of
padding is gonna make a difference right
yeah I mean you're going fast you're
entering high out of the halfpipe or
hitting a jump or whatever I feel like
if you fall I mean I don't think pillows
are gonna make the difference right I'm
still going with pillows when I could be
yeah you have had many injuries can you
just rattle off some of the injuries
you've had
yeah I'm recovering I just recovered
this season from a broken femur and I
blew my knee and then I've broken my
sternum collarbone wrists tibia fibia
yeah I chipped this tooth in the back
I'll show you later it was peanut
brittle don't go near peanut brittle is
what I would say to you you actually
fear one of the events that you're in
right there's you it gives you it it
fills you with the same dread and that
is the half pipe is that right it scares
you yeah can we show you can talk over
this but this is you doing the half pipe
and what are you thinking at that moment
right there I don't know you're kind of
not well you can see how I just barely
kind of clip the deck the corner of
where it goes from the flat wall yeah
that was a mistake I've done that
differently yeah yeah it was a mistake
but when you're going really high if you
clip that I mean it's like solid eyes so
it can kind of buck you into the middle
of the halfpipe and the walls are 22
feet tall so if you air 20 feet out and
then you clip the corner
you're falling like 42 feet with a
little bump in the middle and you just
talked me out of this sport you know on
that last clip I think you can see as
you're backing up there's this you have
a giant bruise yeah
on your back
is that that's that's that's from
probably a pre just a previous event or
with a completely unrelated no it's it's
I mean it like all season long I'll have
stuff like that going on my legs in my
back and just deal with it
yeah it kind of comes with it comes with
the territory I say one of the your ways
of dealing with your fear is singing
while you ski is that right I do um I am
just gonna interject because I thought
we were gonna talk about this skiing and
or the singing I went to karaoke last
night mhm at AK bar in Silver Lake and I
was with my my boyfriend does Broadway I
was with another guy that just Broadway
apparently everyone in LA is a
professional singer I know that I'm
never doing karaoke again right people
get up and they're like this is my
chance to get a job like yeah we're at
like karaoke another scene oh it's not
like in like in Denver you can like
throw up on the stage and it's like you
did such a good job doesn't mean I win I
had like four people come up to me
afterwards they're like that was so
courageous that you saying like
a gay bar and a bunch of the guys came
up into like it's a really good thing
your your cue that you're lucky your cue
and I'm like oh my god I'll never sing a
karaoke again
I've actually been with people who are
really good singers and you just feel
like you just ruin it for everybody
that's just beep litter like I'm not
even shine enough and I'm I feel like
I'm generally like just so competitive
that I I kind of have a hard time doing
things that I'm so bad at but I was like
it's fun it's karaoke everyone loves
karaoke people don't love karaoke if
you're not good at it yeah yeah we're
not watching kids this is important yeah
don't do it this is not what I thought
would end what your warning children
again yeah forget going 20 feet in the
air don't do karaoke
wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my
youtube channel for an endless supply of
me
[Laughter]